Hey youtubers it's Charlie and this week is
comic con so I wanted to do a preview for
Walking Dead explaining all the stuff that's
going on there with the show, like the season
5 trailer and the panel along with the separate
Comic Book stuff Robert Kirkman will be doing
on his own.
Just like I did for Game of Thrones last night.
I'm also doing a special Walking Dead Comic
Con giveaway this week that I'll explain at
the end here.
Hello any new people, if you're finding me
for the first time.
I do weekly Walking Dead videos.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I know I just said I'm doing a comic con giveaway,
but I also do a weekly Walking Dead giveaway
when the actual episodes start.
Big stuff first, there are two big panels,
one documentary screening and two Robert Kirkman
Comics related panels.
So there will be Walking Dead stuff happening
each of the four days Thursday through Sunday.
The Big Hall H Panel where they'll be screening
the Season 5 Trailer is Friday July 25th at
12 Pacific Time.
Since Game of Thrones is beating Walking Dead
in the poll I've been running I'll be uploading
zombies after dragons.
But both of those will post by Friday Night.
I have links to my twitter and facebook down
in the description.
I will be tweeting during the panel.
We're not allowed to post the trailer online
before AMC does, but as soon as they do I'll
do a separate breakdown video for that.
They will post it online on their official
channel, so don't worry.
Everyone will be able to see it by Saturday.
I'm absolutely positive it will make you excited
and sick to your stomach at the same time.
They're bringing a bunch of the main cast
for that including Andrew Lincoln, Norman
Reedus, who's actually doing a separate panel
with Robert Kirkman I'll explain in a sec,
Steven Yeun, Lauren Cohan, Danai Gurira, Melissa
McBride, Chad Coleman, Michael Cudlitz, Scott
Gimple Gale Ann Hurd, Kirkman, Greg Nicotero
and David Alpert.
So basically almost everyone that got stuffed
into Traincar A at Terminus.
Chris Hardwick is moderating just like last
year.
Yes I am a partner at Nerdist, but they don't
produce Talking Dead, that's a separate company.
So I don't get any special treatment or anything.
I stuff myself into Hall H like Sardine just
like everyone else.
They're still in the middle of filming Season
5, but they've been going full steam since
May so they should be almost done filming
the first half of the season if not more.
I just say that based on last year's production
schedule.
They didn't finish filming the Season 4 Finale
until November.
They will announce the premiere date even
though I think we all expect it to be the
second week in October just like last year.
That would put it on October 12th.
But they could always bump it by a week.
They just revealed the full banner they made
just for comic con.
It's basically all the people inside that
traincare chained up.
Wouldn't that suck if they daisy-chained all
those handcuffs together.
They'd have to shuffle around Terminus as
one giant glob of people.
Next up is a special Robert Kirkman Norman
Reedus Panel on Saturday at 3 o'clock Pacific
Time.
It's for their new movie called Air.
They made it through Kirkman's Skybound Label.
It stars Norman Reedus, that's why he's on
the panel.
It's not a Walking Dead movie it doesn't involve
those characters.
It stars Reedus and Djimon Honsou as two workers
in an underground bunker that have to keep
it running in a post-apocalyptic world where
above ground the air has been toxic.
So everyone has to live in a series of underground
bunkers.
It has the DNA of Walking Dead in that it's
post apocalyptic.
The movie won't be out till Spring 2015, but
they will be showing the trailer.
And for those that don't know, Skybound is
Robert Kirkman's company that he started after
he became a partner at Image Comics.
He uses it to publish the comic book.
Now he's using that company to make movies
and video games.
During that AIR panel they'll also be talking
about what's coming next from the Telltale
Walking Dead game and other games they're
developing.
Now Rewind to Thursday, Robert Kirman's Walking
Dead Comic Book Panel is at 4:15PM.
He'll just be talking about the comic and
answering All out War and New Beginning Questions.
I'm not current on the comic right now but
I know a lot of you read along with the show
even though they're not always the same.
Volume 23 is going to be the next storyline
after New Beginning, so they'll probably be
teasing that too.
The last issue of New Beginning is 132, that's
being released October 8th.
Which also supports the theory that Season
5 of the show will premiere the following
Sunday.
There's another panel for a Walking Dead Documentary
on Friday at 5:30PM Pacific Time.
It's called a Decade of Dead.
It's just about the evolution of the comic
and how it turned into a TV Show.
It's only 20 minutes long, so they'll probably
add it to one of the DVDs eventually or maybe
even air it on TV.
Then on Sunday at 11AM Robert Kirkman is doing
another Comic Book Panel for the other comics
he publishes through skybound like Ghosted,
Tech Jacket and Manifest Destiny.
Which are all really cool.
So you should check those out if you're already
reading the Walking Dead comic.
AMC as usual is bringing their Walking Dead
Escape Event, that's going to be outside the
convention center, so you don't need a badge
to go see it.
It's at PetCo Park and it's only going to
be open on Friday and Saturday.
But it's one of the cooler things to do if
you don't have a comic con badge.
You do have to buy separate tickets for it.
There's different levels you can buy ranging
from 20 to 70 dollars.
But it's really cool.
The website for those tickets is the walking
dead escape dot com.
If you buy the expensive tickets, the 70 dollar
ones, they basically turn you into a walker
and train you like they train the walkers
on the show.
You get full on make up done too.
That's why it costs so much.
There is some really cool merch Skybound is
selling.
You can Buy Negan's Lucille Bat, there's a
new Ezekiel figure.
I won't say where he comes from because spoilers.
And then there's a bunch of new minis including
Jesus, Abraham and Andrea.
Those will all be sold at the Skybound booth
as long as they have supplies.
So get there before Sunday.
They'll probably sell them online eventually
for anyone not going.
So don't worry.
So big reminders, I will be uploading the
Walking Dead Hall H panel Friday Night.
Internet is really crappy there but the video
should be up by midnight.
And I'll do a separate video for the Season
5 trailer as soon as it posts.
Probably Saturday if not also Friday Night.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I will be tweeting during it, so if you want
to follow me all my social links are at the
bottom of the description.
Here's the details on my giveaway.
I'm going to be picking one random subscriber
from the comments on this video to get a funko
pop figure of your choice.
So you can pick like Poncho Daryl or The Governor
or whoever's available.
The giveaway will be open till the week after
Comic Con, so I won't pick a winner till next
week.
Right now click here to learn about the new
characters coming to season 5 and click here
for a breakdown of the Season 5 Special they
just aired
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!